well guess what everybody it is time for
drew's news your back scratcher that
really gets that good news itch and with
me at the desk well i've got two amazing
co-pilots today
queen of the yemo rachel wreck yeah
rachel ray i am so excited long-time
fans oh my god i'm obsessed with rachel
ray i check your instagram my kind well
the word is stalk but i'm there and i'm
watching i'm cute i adore you
we've known each other for years many
years i know this is so exciting i'm
really excited for the news we have
today um are you ready yes okay
if you're looking for a hot date have
you tried the back of an uber
because that's where one couple from
boston had their meat cute the
washington post reports that mark and
rachel both called an uber pool on
halloween night a few years ago rachel
got in dressed as a dalmatian and
immediately hit it off with mark who was
dressed as mark
four years later they just got married
oh
my god
the only thing i found in an uber were
some free mints and a weird stain that i
really wanted to attack
but
how hopeful is this yes this is you
never know where this person could be
you can be in traffic and then find
yourself doing a little bump at a bumper
later if you know what i mean
i love love we dork out about it all the
time and i know that you have a wedding
coming up not your own but you're
officiating bob harper's wedding yeah
next year he asked me i get it i get to
wear tom ford's suit oh
i know uh-huh
i'm very excited about it i have my
little packet
i will be rev
rey rev gray the reverend
yeah that would be really fun really i
just love that you know you never know
when you can meet someone that'll just
change your life i just celebrated our
16th uh anniversary though
and i've been together
21 years but we've been married for 16.
the same year we started the show when
you met was it cute like you know this
uber story sort of
a person tried to set us up and
that person had a party and everyone at
this party
was um very tall um
they were a lot of actors and models and
john and i are very short and john says
we saw each other across the sea of
knees so we literally crossed a crowded
room started talking to each other and
i've been with john on the telephone or
in person every night for 21 years since
oh my
gosh
speaking of decisions that last a
lifetime there's a new tattoo in town
did you hear about this one vice reports
the trendiest tattoo of the moment is
the qr code
you don't write those little codes at
the table of the restaurant um where you
can scan out
what the appetizers are or shop in any
retail i understand wait okay so you
know those little codes
like what's on it like when you scan
your body that's the point people are
getting the personalized qr code that
will lead them to their resume their
favorite song
proof of vaccination hard pass
if i ever did this i would get a link to
that bed bath and beyond 20 off coupon
because i can never find that how easy
would that be just like
i think that is
thank you like you think it's crazy i
think it's horrible i think it's creepy
and orwellian and i don't want you
knowing anything about me much less
scamming me really no it is super
orwellian yeah very creepy creepy creepy
drew got a tattoo on this show i have it
right here
yes it says home is where we are which
is a love letter to me and my girls
because it's true anywhere we go
as long as we're together that is home
that's literally what i wrote that book
about about the definition of home i
mean this book
is so moving to me i love it so much and
i feel
like it's one of the most intimate of
yours which is funny because the hardest
to write yeah i feel like you're so
giving of yourself but this one i feel
like really just goes deep
into the things that you've experienced
in the last two years so the book begins
actually where we felt like we lost our
privacy it was a big deal to start
filming
from home then we literally lost our dog
of over 15 years our beloved isabel and
then our house burned down like the
first day we took off um
once the season ended and no matter what
we lost i just kept thinking how lucky
we were to be with
our animal
at the end of her life and how many
people were robbed of that moment with
their loved ones you know yeah it's
really a much happier book than i'm
making this yeah
well
i think
that it's incredibly optimistic
and i thank you so much for sharing it i
really really love
it it's incredible
and
let me keep it real though because my
bra just gave up on the right-hand side
well don't you love that when only half
of it quits
and
we're gonna cut to commercial i'm gonna
help you we'll be right back
[Music]